he's gonna kill Martha what are you
saying why did you say that find him
save Martha why did you say that name
Martha what did you say anything
what all right now you know Zack I'm
just not feeling this I'm just I don't
know man I don't think it's working
what's the problem now Ben I just don't
understand how both their mothers having
the same name could make them friends so
quickly you know I was about to stab him
you don't get this character at all do
you
we need to see them connect on a basic
level I feel connected shut up Henry
you talk what I tell you to sir ah yeah
that's right go practice your brooding
now what do Batman and Superman have in
common
come on they both fight for truth and
justice wrong they want to help people
no they've got man at the end of their
killers Ben killers have you seen Man of
Steel have you read the script these
guys have been stone-cold murderers are
the comics for you that's how it's
always been I'm cool what comment says
do it right or brain get mad David okay
got it all right let's go people
tell Heisenberg ease neck
I'm not gonna kill you I'm just gonna
hurt you really really great job Jared I
think this design will look awesome in
the movie yeah I really like it I don't
care what you want Nolan doomsday will
be in this movie hasn't hated Suicide
Squad true
hi there oh is this what the Joker's
gonna look like well it's not finished
but I'm pretty sure we're getting I hate
it
what it's a traditional design it's what
David wants David schmayman I'm still in
charge of these final decisions now this
has all got to go we need a body Joker
to see the crazy but also how do you
just need to Waddle sex cells and I need
a real sexy psychopath
dr. ran the lips the jackets got to go
actually the shirt - okay what's with
the white gloves is he Mickey Mouse who
wants to fuck Mickey Mouse
well what gloves do you want leather no
latex surgical gloves probably what like
Michael Jackson
I'm still not happy with about it is to
look tougher like a rapper something
gimbal grill a grill ooh
face tattoos that's just crazy like face
tattoos like a teardrop Jade air high or
something
double meeting the Joker isn't that bad
of a guy right
he's Bora just kind of damage yes
okay still needs a bunch more tattoos
but we got to do this quick I've got a
meeting with Mel Gibson at 4:00 and he
is gonna make a great penguin hurry up
I'll give it to me perfect later
who said you won't have any dead rats
lying around what am i late hold on just
a minute here
see that's not her yeah would you expect
Jon Favreau listen your director what
happened in the Russo brothers i
kidnapped bob iger and fourth season to
give me the job I mean uh they watched
300 and they thought I'd be perfect it
directed a war movie that is what this
is right uh a big ol warbling well it's
Civil War but have you even read the
comic then what the what all right let's
get started
Iron Man yeah that costumes a little
bright don't you think Wow we got
something in black for the caffeine free
cocaine over here
Percy come with me
much better what are you doing
Ironman doesn't wear black what is what
is this this is Marvel Studios a Captain
America movie it's supposed to be
colorful it's a comic book we're light
hearted but still give you deep
character moments no kid friendly but
still deal with adult themed situations
and character driven relationships good
writing mixed with fun is any of this
getting through to you are you a girl
what have you done to me
you've been Snyder talk to me what I
escaped first we got to get the hell out
of here
all righty people it's been a while but
these folks are ready to get back in the
game please help me welcome back to pop
culture the Ghostbusters who are you
gonna call
all right you know
what's wrong with you people that was
the greatest thing I've ever seen in my
life
and I'm very hard to impress